ONE REPUBLICAN, THIS IS EXPECTED
TO PASS BY A NARROW MARGIN,
JASON BACK TO YOU.
>> Jason: CHAD, THANK YOU.
JOINING US WITH REACTION HOUSE
MAJORITY STEVE SCALISE, THE
CHAIRMAN MATCHED WITH THE
FAVORITE NEW YORK CONGRESSMAN
LEE ZELDIN AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR CHARLIE HURT.
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING ALL OF US WITH US
TONIGHT.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU,
STEVE SCALISE.
I HAVE GOT TO TELL YOU, THIS
DOES GIVE NANCY PELOSI MORE
POWER WHEN SHE TELLS MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, YOU DON’T EVEN NEED TO
SHOW UP ANYMORE.
AND WE CAN VOTE WITHOUT YOU,
RIGHT?
>> YES, JASON IT GIVES
NANCY PELOSI POWER, BUT IMAGINE
BEING A DEMOCRAT THAT GOES BACK
HOME IN A SWING DISTRICT.
YOU JUST VOTED TO GIVE YOUR
VOTING CARD IN CONGRESS TO
NANCY PELOSI.
SHE DOESN’T REPRESENT THE VALUES
OF A LOT OF THOSE DISTRICTS.
YOU KNOW YOU SIGNED ON FOR
SAN FRANCISCO VALUES AND BY THE
WAY, WHAT ARE YOU DOING THAT AND
WHY ARE YOU COLLECTING A
PAYCHECK IF YOU WANT
NANCY PELOSI TO BE THE ONE TO
VOTE FOR YOU AND REPRESENT YOUR
DISTRICT AND YOU ARE
REPRESENTING A SWING STATE
SOMEWHERE ELSE?
THIS WILL BE A TOUGH VOTE FOR
PEOPLE TO EXPLAIN.
IT IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL FIRST OF
ALL, BECAUSE A QUORUM UNDER THIS
RESOLUTION THEY PASSED HIM A 20
PEOPLE ON THE FLOOR.
20 DEMOCRATS CAN CONSTITUTE A
FORM OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, 435 PEOPLE.
THAT GOES AGAINST ARTICLE 1 OF
THE CONSTITUTION BUT THEY DON’T
CARE ABOUT THAT, THEY WANT TO
CONSOLIDATE POWER AND SPEND
MONEY.
A DRUNKEN SAILOR WOULD BE
IMPLANTED TO BE COMPARED TO THEM
WITH WHAT THEY DO BUT THIS BILL,
ILLEGAL, TAXPAYER FUNDING WITH
ABORTION.
>> Jason: CONGRESSMAN I HAVE
TO ASK YOU, DOES THIS MEAN YOU
WILL CHALLENGE THIS IN COURT?
WILL YOU GO TO COURT AND
CHALLENGE THE CONSTITUTIONALITY
OF THIS?
>> IF THEY PASS ANY BILL USING
THESE NEW RULES, THEY HAVEN’T
DONE IT YET, BUT THEY ARE
CREATING THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE 20 PEOPLE ON THE BOARD THE
CONSTITUTE A FORM AND
NANCY PELOSI TO HOLD THE VOTING
COURTS HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE.
IT WILL BE CHALLENGED.
>> Jason: THAT WILL BE
INTERESTING BECAUSE I BELIEVE
YOU WOULD CERTAINLY HAVE
STANDING, CONGRESSMAN SELDEN,
THIS VOTE BEING VOTED ON ON THE
VERGE OF PASSING $3 TRILLION.
THIS THING IS LOADED UP WITH ALL
KINDS OF THINGS.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS BILL?
>> OVER 1800 PAGES, $3 TRILLION
AND THIS ISN’T A BILL DRAFTED BY
PARTISANSHIP, DEBATES,
COMPROMISE, NONE OF THAT.
IT GIVES A STIMULUS CHECK TO
PEOPLE ILLEGALLY IN THE COUNTRY,
MASSIVE PRISON DELAYS, LEGALIZES
THROUGHOUT THEIR HARVESTING.
AND IT OUTLAWS VOTER I.D.
IT EXTENDS UNEMPLOYMENT IN A WAY
THAT WILL KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF
WORK FOR ALMOST ANOTHER YEAR.
I WILL ADD ANOTHER ONE TO THAT
COMMIT PROVIDES MORE MONEY WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS AND BEYOND
WHAT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
EVEN ASKING ASKING FOR.
SPEAKER PELOSI CHOSE BIPARTISAN
PASS TO NOWHERE RATHER THAN
PURSUING THE ALTERNATIVE WHICH
WAS WORKING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WORKING WITH
CONGRESSIONAL REPUBLICANS AND
TRIED TO NEGOTIATE A COMPROMISE.
THIS IS SOMETHING TO APPEASE HER
LEFT FLANK.
THIS IS ONE THAT TURNS OFF MOST
OF AMERICA, AND SHE IS GOING TO
END UP WITH A BILL DEAD ON
ARRIVAL IN THE SENATE AND NOT
GOING ANYWHERE.
IT IS A STRATEGIC FAILURE ON HER
PART ON MULTIPLE LEVELS COME ON
THE SUBSTANCE AND THIS IS A
WASTE OF EVERYONE’S TIME AND
CERTAINLY A LOT OF TAX DOLLARS,
ESPECIALLY THE LIBERAL ITEMS
TOTALLY UNRELATED TO CORONAVIRUS
RESPONSE.
>> Jason: MATT IF YOU SPEND A
MILLION DOLLARS EVERY DAY IT
WOULD TAKE YOU 3,000 YEARS TO
GET TO $1 TRILLION AND THIS IS
$3 TRILLION.
THAT IS $10,000 PER PERSON IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA SO
WHY NOT GIVE THEM $10,000 EACH?
>> THANKS FOR DOING THE MATH FOR
ME, JASON, BECAUSE IT IS
STAGGERING.
WE ALREADY DID $3 TRILLION.
I THINK WHAT REPUBLICANS ARE
SAYING WHICH IS RATIONAL, LET’S
LET ALL OF THE MONEY.
WE HAVE ALREADY SPENT LIKE
DRUNKEN SAILORS BECAUSE THE
GOVERNMENT SHUT DOWN AMERICAN
BUSINESSES.
LET THAT CAPITALIZE IN THE
SYSTEM.
JASON, THIS IS THE CRITICAL
POINT, WHICH IS MORE BRIDGES AND
MORE STIMULUS IS NOT WHAT THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY NOR ITS PEOPLE
NEED.
THEY NEED TO BE LEGALLY ALLOWED
TO GO BACK TO WORK.
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO OPEN UP
THEIR SHOPS.
IF YOU ARE A MOM AND POP, YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE OPEN LIKE
THE BIG BOX RETAILERS ARE ABLE
TO BE OPEN.
WE HAVE THIS INDISCRIMINATE
SILLY RULES BY MOST BLUE STATE
GOVERNORS, AND IT NEEDS TO END.
NO BUSINESS CAN SURVIVE IF IT
CAN’T MAKE A PRODUCT NOR
TRANSACT WITH CUSTOMERS.
IT IS SIMPLY THAT CLEAR.
>> Jason: NOW, CHARLIE THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE TRIED TO SAY OH,
WE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER.
WE HAVE TO FIND SOMETHING THAT
IS BIPARTISAN BUT NANCY PELOSI
DID NOT DO ANY OF THAT.
THEY SAY ONE THING AND DO
SOMETHING TOTALLY OPPOSITE.
HOW IN THE WORLD TO THEY GO BACK
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND SAY
HEY, WE ARE THE ADULTS IN THE
ROOM AND WE WILL WORK TOGETHER
TO GET THINGS DONE WHEN THEY PUT
THIS MONSTROSITY IN FRONT OF THE
CONGRESS AND THEN VOTE TO SAY,
HEY, WE DON’T NEED TO COME BACK
IN SESSION.
>> IT IS INCREDIBLE.
THEY SHOULD BE A REAL WAKE-UP
CALL BECAUSE IF ANYBODY DOUBTS
WHAT IS AT STAKE IN THIS
ELECTION COMING UP, THIS IS WHAT
IS AT STAKE.
THIS IS WHAT THESE PEOPLE WILL
DO.
IF THEY CAN HOLD CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE, THEY GET CONTROL OF THE
SENATE AND LORD FORBID THEY GET
CONTROL OF THE WHITE HOUSE, THIS
IS THE KIND OF INSANITY THAT YOU
WILL BE LOOKING AT.
AND OF COURSE, I’VE SEEN THE
PARTICULARS ARE JUST ASTONISHING
ASTONISHING.
THE SOFT ILLEGAL ALIENS FROM ALL
OF THAT STUFF IS ABSOLUTELY,
JUST ABSOLUTELY REPREHENSIBLE.
BUT LET’S STEP BACK FOR A
MINUTE.
HOW IN THE WORLD DOES PILING
$3 TRILLION IN ADDITIONAL DEBT
ON HARDWORKING AMERICANS, HOW
DOES THAT HELP THEM RECOVER FROM
THIS PANDEMIC AND RECOVER FROM
SHUTTING DOWN THE ECONOMY?
AND WE SHOULD LOOK BACK.
IMAGINE WHERE WE WOULD BE RIGHT
NOW, JASON, HAD WE NOT PILED UP
$20 TRILLION OF DEBT ON
HARDWORKING AMERICAN TAXPAYERS?
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE WANT TO DO
IS I WILL MORE AND MORE ON
THERE.
AND WITH THAT COMES JUST
MOUNTAINS OF REGULATIONS THAT
THROTTLE AMERICAN INGENUITY AND
INDUSTRY AND WORK THAT DESTROYS
AMERICANS.
THEY WERE IN CONGRESSMAN
SCALISE, YOU ARE IN LEADERSHIP
THERE.
NANCY PELOSI AND WHAT SHE HAS
DONE IS SIGNALED ALSO IN THE
BILL THAT THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES MAY NOT COME
BACK INTO SESSION UNTIL
JULY 21ST.
I MEAN I’M A WHY DO MEMBERS OF
COMMON COURTESY GET PAID IF THEY
DON’T HAVE TO GO TO WORK?
POSTAL WORKERS GO TO WORK.
TRUCKERS WILL GO TO WORK.
HEALTH CARE WORKERS GO TO WORK,
BUT NANCY PELOSI IS SAYING, NO
NEED TO SHOW UP TO WORK ANYMORE.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE EVEN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE IS GOING TO
WORK.
THERE IS NO REASON.
WE WERE HERE TODAY VOTING.
THERE WERE ABOUT 24 MEMBERS WHO
COULDN’T MAKE IT OUT OF 435 AND
SO TO SUGGEST IT IS COMPLICATED
TO GET HERE MACK’S FALLACY.
THE WAY SHE DID THIS, IT IS
ABOUT A POWER GRAB AND CERTAINLY
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH HEALTH
AND SAFETY.
AS YOU MENTIONED, WE HAVE THE
FRONT LINE WORKERS BACK IN THE
HOSPITALS, GROCERY STORES AND
OUT IN LOUISIANA TODAY WE
STARTED OPENING UP SO YOU CAN GO
INTO A RESTAURANT WITH FINALLY
GOING INTO PLACES OF WORSHIP.
AND YET, SHE WILL SAY THAT SHE
DOESN’T WANT CONGRESS TO BE
MEETING IN WASHINGTON, DEBATING
BILLS, BUT SHE WOULD RATHER TAKE
YOUR PROXY VOTE AND HOLD ONTO IT
SO SHE CAN VOTE FOR YOU.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS AND OF
COURSE, JASON, YOU WOULD NOT DO
THIS EITHER, NANCY PELOSI WOULD
NOT GET MY BOW AND SHE SURE
WOULDN’T GET YOURS BUT ANYONE
THAT VOTED FOR THIS BILL TODAY,
HOW DO THEY GO BACK HOME AND
EXPLAIN TODAY THEY VOTED TO
ALLOW NANCY PELOSI TO VOTE FOR
THEM SO THEY DON’T HAVE TO GO TO
WORK ANYMORE?
WHY DON’T THEY JUST RESIGN THEIR
SEAT AND SEND SOMEBODY UP HERE
HE WANTS TO COME AND FIGHT UP
HERE IN WASHINGTON.
>> Jason: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CONGRESSMAN ZELDIN, LAST WORD
CALMLY WE HAVE 15 SECONDS.
>> IF THERE IS A MEMBER OF HOUSE
LEADERSHIP VIEWING THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES IS NOT ESSENTIAL
THAT HOUSE LEADERSHIP MANAGEMENT
SHOULD STEP ASIDE.
IF THERE IS ANY OF THE HOUSE,
NONESSENTIAL THEY SHOULD STEP
ASIDE APPEARED WE SHOULD BE
HERE.
WE SHOULD NOT BE GOING HOME
RIGHT NOW.
THERE IS AN IMPORTANT WORK TO DO
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
ECONOMY, BUSINESSES, THE WORKERS
AND EVERYONE IS LEAVING.
YOU POINTED OUT IT MIGHT BE A